Robots are steadily improving at many tasks,
and even outdoing humans at some of them.
But they’re still incredibly clumsy when
it comes to fine motor movements in small
small joints, like our hands.
Typically, even toddlers can blow the most
cutting edge robots out of the water when
it comes to incorporating feedback into how
we touch, move or grip things.
For example, when you get into a new car with
a gas pedal more sensitive than your old one,
you adjust your foot pressure accordingly.
Your brain, your body, and the environment
work together to help you determine the right
movement and execute it.
Researchers wanted to build robots capable
of using this three-pronged approach – mind,
body, environment - to execute
more complex and sensitive movements.
So they used 3D printing to create a skeleton-like
hand, integrating materials with different
flexibilities to simulate the complex arrangement
of bones, joints, and ligaments in the human hand.
They built several hands with different levels
of stiffness in each joint to see what kind
of behaviors they could achieve.
To test the ability of the skeleton hand to
perform challenging mechanical tasks, they
had it play piano music in different styles,
something that can trip up even the most dexterous
of humans.
The hand was able to play the piano using
the staccato technique with slightly shortened,
bouncy notes.
It could also play glissando, where you slide
smoothly between the notes
The researchers analyzed how much force the
robot was using and how quickly it was hitting
each note, and they found a strong match to the
force and timing of a human playing the same
pieces.
While the skeleton hand did not capture all
of the complexities of the human hand, the researchers
see it as a step forward in creating robots
capable of more complex, nuanced interactions
with objects in their environment, by taking
advantage of the natural flexibility of the
human hand.
The hands could be one day be used for a variety
of job that require a delicate touch like
picking fruit off of trees or feeling for
tumors or unusual tissues.
But for now, they’ll stick to tickling the
ivories, and they might even have a festive
song or two up their sleeves.